selamat kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah pengarah teknikal untuk pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini ialah pelajaran nombor 15 siri ini dan merupakan pelajaran ketiga unit keempat yang berkaitan dengan pembetulan ralat
kuantum setakat ini kita telah melihat beberapa contoh kod pembetulan ralat kuantum termasuk kod Shore sembilan
qubit kod Steane 7 qubit dan kod 5 qubit dan kita juga telah bincangkan formalisme penstabil yang memberi
kita asas matematik dari mana kita boleh menerangkan dan menganalisis kod-kod ini dan banyak lagi kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang lain
kod-kod yang baru saya sebut tidak diragui menarik dan ia mewakili tempat permulaan yang semula jadi untuk
penerokaan pembetulan ralat kuantum masalahnya ialah ia hanya boleh bertolak ansur dengan kadar ralat yang sangat rendah
membetulkan ralat pada satu qubit daripada lima tujuh atau sembilan bukan buruk tapi kemungkinan besar sekurang-kurangnya sejauh yang kita syaki
kita akan perlu mampu bertolak ansur dengan lebih banyak ralat daripada itu untuk menjadikan Pengiraan Kuantum berskala besar satu
kenyataan dalam pelajaran ini kita akan lihat pertama kali beberapa pembinaan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang lebih canggih termasuk kod yang boleh
bertolak ansur dengan kadar ralat yang jauh lebih tinggi daripada yang kita lihat sejauh ini dan dilihat sebagai calon yang menjanjikan untuk pembetulan ralat kuantum praktikal dalam
peranti fizikal sebenar ini adalah gambaran ringkas pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan kelas
kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang dikenali sebagai kod CSS dinamakan sempena penyelidik yang mula-mula menemuinya Robert Calderbank Peter
Shor dan Andrew Steane pembinaan kod CSS membolehkan seseorang mengambil pasangan tertentu kod pembetulan ralat klasik
dan menggabungkannya menjadi kod pembetulan ralat kuantum sebagai sebahagian perbincangan itu kita akan
lihat dengan cukup pantas kod linear klasik dan kita juga akan bincangkan beberapa sifat asas kod
CSS bahagian kedua pelajaran ini berkaitan dengan kod yang dikenali sebagai kod Torus yang merupakan contoh asas dan sungguh
cantik kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang boleh bertolak ansur dengan kadar ralat yang agak tinggi sebenarnya
kod Torus bukan satu contoh tunggal kod pembetulan ralat kuantum tapi sebaliknya ia adalah keluarga tak terhingga kod satu untuk
setiap integer positif bermula dari dua dan dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran kita akan sebutkan secara ringkas beberapa
keluarga kod kuantum lain termasuk kod permukaan yang berkaitan rapat dengan kod Torus serta
kod warna orang telah mengkaji kod pembetulan ralat klasik sejak tahun 1940-an
dan ia adalah subjek yang menakjubkan dan kaya kod linear mungkin jenis kod pembetulan ralat klasik yang paling mudah
dan saya akan jelaskan dengan tepat apa maksud kata linear dalam konteks ini sebentar lagi tapi satu cara mudah
untuk nyatakan apa adanya ialah ia adalah kod penstabil yang kebetulan klasik dan kita akan lihat tidak lama lagi bahawa
kod CSS pada dasarnya adalah pasangan kod linear klasik yang digabungkan bersama untuk mewujudkan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum
jadi demi perbincangan itu kita perlu faham beberapa perkara asas tentang
kod linear klasik pertama kita akan ambil Sigma sebagai abjad binari untuk keseluruhan
perbincangan ini dan sekarang apabila kita merujuk kepada kod linear klasik kita bermaksud set C rentetan binari panjang n untuk sesetengah
integer positif n yang memenuhi hanya satu sifat asas iaitu jika u dan v adalah rentetan binari dalam C maka rentetan
u XOR v juga ada dalam C di sini ngomong-ngomong u XOR v bermaksud OR eksklusif bit demi bit bagi u dan v sama sahaja
seperti yang kita lihat beberapa kali dalam pelajaran lima dan enam dalam bahagian algoritma kuantum siri ini dan inilah maksudnya untuk
kod klasik menjadi linear pada dasarnya kita memikirkan rentetan binari panjang n sebagai vektor n-dimensi
di mana entri-entrinya semuanya sama ada sifar atau satu tapi bukannya penambahan vektor biasa ke atas nombor nyata atau kompleks
kita menggunakan penambahan modulo 2 yang hanyalah XOR jadi jika kita ada
dua perkataan kod u dan v yang bermaksud u dan v adalah rentetan binari dalam C maka u tambah v modulo 2 atau dalam erti kata lain u XOR
v mesti juga merupakan perkataan kod dalam C dan ngomong-ngomong implikasi ini mesti benar walaupun u sama dengan v tiada yang menghalang
kemungkinan itu dan itu bermakna setiap kod linear klasik mesti mengandungi rentetan semua sifar kerana
XOR bit demi bit mana-mana rentetan dengan dirinya sendiri ialah rentetan semua sifar misalnya kod
pengulangan tiga bit adalah kod linear klasik khususnya ada dua kemungkinan pilihan untuk u dan dua kemungkinan
pilihan untuk v dan agak mudah untuk melalui pasangan yang mungkin untuk lihat bahawa kita sentiasa mendapat perkataan kod apabila kita ambil XOR bit demi bit
ini pula satu lagi contoh yang dipanggil kod Hamming 743 ini adalah salah satu kod pembetulan ralat klasik yang terawal
yang pernah ditemui dan ia terdiri daripada 16 rentetan binari panjang tujuh ada logik yang sangat mudah
di sebalik pemilihan rentetan-rentetan ini tapi saya tidak akan jelaskan itu dalam video ini dan saya juga perlu sebut bahawa anda kadang-kadang akan lihat rentetan-rentetan ini terbalik tapi
buat masa ini poin utama ialah jika kita ambil mana-mana dua rentetan ini dan XOR-kannya bersama kita akan mendapat rentetan lain dalam
kod itu jadi ia adalah kod linear dan notasi 743 dalam kurungan persegi tunggal bermaksud sesuatu yang analogus dengan notasi kurungan persegi berganda
bukan yang saya sebut dalam pelajaran sebelumnya untuk kod penstabil tapi di sini ia adalah untuk kod linear klasik
khususnya perkataan-perkataan kod mempunyai tujuh bit ada 16 perkataan kod jadi kita boleh enkod empat bit menggunakan kod itu dan
ia kebetulan adalah kod jarak tiga yang bermaksud anda perlu balikkan sekurang-kurangnya tiga bit mana-mana perkataan kod untuk mendapat
perkataan kod yang berbeza dan itu bermakna ia boleh membetulkan sehingga satu ralat balik bit ini adalah contoh mudah
kod tapi malah contoh kod Hamming 743 kelihatan semacam misteri apabila kita cukup senaraikan semua perkataan kod jadi kita perlukan cara yang lebih baik untuk
menerangkan kod linear klasik dan ada dua cara semula jadi untuk melakukan ini satu cara ialah menerangkan kod linear klasik
dengan memberikan set minimum perkataan kod yang menjana kod yang bermaksud dengan mengambil semua subset yang mungkin
perkataan-perkataan kod ini dan XOR-kannya bersama kita mendapat keseluruhan kod dan itu dinyatakan dalam istilah matematik
di sini di skrin cara lain untuk memikirkan tentang ini ialah kita melihat kod ini sebagai subruang ruang vektor dan set
penjana ini adalah asas bagi subruang itu perlu diingat bahawa ini adalah ruang vektor di mana aritmetik dilakukan modulo 2 jika kita ada M penjana kita akan
mendapat kod yang mempunyai dua kepangkat m elemen setiap penjana menggandakan bilangan elemen dalam kod dan
itu bersesuaian dengan fakta bahawa kod linear klasik ke atas abjad binari sentiasa mengandungi bilangan rentetan yang merupakan kuasa
dua cara kedua yang semula jadi untuk menerangkan kod linear klasik ialah melalui pemeriksaan pariti khususnya ini adalah senarai minimum
rentetan binari yang mempunyai panjang yang sama dengan rentetan-rentetan dalam kod sedemikian rupa sehingga rentetan-rentetan dalam kod itu tepat yang hasil darab binari
dengan setiap rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini adalah sifar di mana hasil darab binari hanyalah hasil darab dalam biasa
WEBVTT
modulo 2 dan sekali lagi itu sesuatu yang kita temui dalam pelajaran lima dalam konteks algoritma
kuantum dan sebab ia dipanggil rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ialah rentetan tertentu U mempunyai hasil darab binari sama dengan
sifar dengan v jika dan hanya jika bit-bit U yang sepadan dengan yang satu dalam v mempunyai pariti
genap apabila kita menerangkan kod linear klasik dengan cara ini melalui senarai minimum rentetan pemeriksaan pariti setiap pemeriksaan pariti
membahagikan bilangan rentetan dalam kod dengan dua jadi untuk satu kod yang diterangkan dalam dua cara berbeza ini kita akan selalu ada m tambah r sama dengan
n satu perkara penting yang perlu diperhatikan di sini ialah hasil darab binari bukan hasil darab dalam secara formal dan
khususnya apabila dua rentetan mempunyai hasil darab binari sama dengan sifar ia tidak bermaksud ia ortogonal dalam cara biasa yang kita fikirkan tentang
ortogonaliti misalnya hasil darab binari rentetan satu satu dengan dirinya sendiri adalah sifar jadi mungkin bahawa
satu daripada rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini sendiri ada dalam kod itu jadi itu hanyalah sesuatu yang perlu diingat
misalnya seperti yang kita tahu kod pengulangan 3-bit adalah kod linear jadi ia boleh diterangkan dalam kedua-dua cara ini
khususnya hanya ada satu pilihan untuk penjana yang berfungsi dan itu ialah 111 dan kita boleh secara alternatif menerangkan
kod dengan dua rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini yang sepatutnya kelihatan familiar dari perbincangan kita sebelumnya tentang
kod ini dan untuk kod Hamming 743 kita boleh gunakan penjana-penjana ini dan pemeriksaan-pemeriksaan pariti ini
dan di sini ngomong-ngomong semua rentetan pemeriksaan pariti kita rupanya sendiri ada dalam kod itu
satu ulasan terakhir tentang kod linear klasik sekadar untuk menghubungkannya dengan formalisme penstabil rentetan-rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini
adalah setara dengan penjana penstabil di mana kita hanya ada matriks polinomial Z dan identiti misalnya pemeriksaan pariti
rentetan 11 0 dan 011 untuk kod pengulangan 3-bit sepadan tepat dengan penjana penstabil ZZ identiti
dan identiti ZZ dan itu bersesuaian dengan perbincangan kita tentang pemboleh ukur jenis ini dari pelajaran sebelumnya
seterusnya kita akan bincangkan kod CSS yang merupakan kod penstabil yang boleh diperoleh dengan menggabungkan bersama pasangan tertentu
kod linear klasik yang mempunyai bilangan bit yang sama dalam pengekodan mereka ini tidak berfungsi untuk mana-mana dua
kod linear klasik kedua-dua kod mesti mempunyai hubungan tertentu seperti yang akan kita lihat tidak lama lagi tapi walau bagaimanapun
pembinaan ini membuka banyak kemungkinan untuk kod pembetulan ralat kuantum sebahagiannya berdasarkan perkara yang kita pelajari dari lebih 75 tahun
Teori Pengekodan klasik saya sudah sebut bahawa dalam formalisme penstabil penjana-penjana penstabil
yang hanya mengandungi matriks polinomial Z dan identiti adalah setara dengan pemeriksaan pariti misalnya dalam kod pengulangan tiga bit
kita boleh gunakan rentetan pemeriksaan pariti 1 1 0 dan 011 yang menguatkuasakan bahawa dua bit paling kiri adalah
sama dan dua bit paling kanan adalah sama untuk setiap rentetan dalam kod dan dua rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini sepadan tepat dengan penjana penstabil
ZZ identiti dan identiti ZZ untuk kod Hamming 743 kita boleh gunakan
rentetan-rentetan pemeriksaan pariti ini dan ia sepadan dengan penjana-penjana penstabil ini di mana kita cukup gantikan setiap satu dengan z dan setiap sifar dengan identiti
anda mungkin kenali penjana-penjana penstabil ini ngomong-ngomong kerana ini adalah tiga daripada enam penjana penstabil untuk kod steam 7 qubit itu
pasti bukan kebetulan dan kita akan lihat dengan tepat apa yang berlaku di sini tidak lama lagi kita akan berikan nama penjana penstabil Z
kepada penjana-penjana penstabil seperti ini yang bermaksud ia hanya mempunyai faktor tensor polinomial Z dan identiti
jadi X dan Y tidak pernah muncul dalam penjana penstabil z kita juga boleh mempertimbangkan
penjana-penjana penstabil di mana hanya matriks polinomial X dan identiti muncul dan kita boleh fikirkan tentang penjana-penjana penstabil seperti ini sebagai sepenuhnya analogus
dengan penjana penstabil Z kecuali bahawa ia pada dasarnya menerangkan pemeriksaan pariti dalam asas plus minus berbanding asas
piawai misalnya kembali kepada kod Hamming 743 kita boleh fikirkan tentang
tiga penjana penstabil selebihnya dari kod steam 7 qubit yang mengikut corak yang sama tepat seperti untuk penjana penstabil Z bagi kod ini
tapi kali ini kita gantikan X dengan satu berbanding Z dan apa yang kita dapat hanya dari tiga penjana penstabil ini
adalah kod yang mengandungi 16 keadaan yang ditunjukkan di sini yang kita dapat dengan menggunakan gate Hadamard ke keadaan asas piawai
yang sepadan dengan rentetan-rentetan dalam kod Hamming 743 dan tentunya ruang kod kita juga mengandungi
gabungan linear keadaan-keadaan ini secara semula jadinya penjana-penjana penstabil berbentuk ini dipanggil penjana penstabil X
jadi tiada y atau z dibenarkan kali ini dan sekarang kita boleh takrifkan kod CSS dalam
istilah mudah kod CSS adalah kod penstabil yang boleh dinyatakan menggunakan hanya penjana penstabil Z
dan penjana penstabil X jadi tiada y dibenarkan dan tiada x dan z yang muncul dalam penjana penstabil yang sama
dan sekedar untuk pastikan ini jelas kita perlu ingat bahawa ada kebebasan dalam cara kita memilih penjana-penjana penstabil untuk kod penstabil
dan apa yang dikatakan takrifan ini ialah kod CSS adalah yang mungkin untuk memilih hanya penjana penstabil Z dan X
tapi secara umumnya anda boleh pilih penjana-penjana penstabil yang berbeza yang mungkin bukan penjana penstabil Z atau X jika anda mahu
ini adalah contoh CSS code yang paling mudah tidak remeh yang boleh kita ada di mana ada penjana penstabil z
dan penjana penstabil X dan mengesahkan itu tidak memerlukan lebih dari sekadar pandangan sekilas memandangkan kita sudah tahu dari
pelajaran sebelumnya bahawa ini adalah kod penstabil yang sah ruang kod itu berdimensi satu ia adalah ruang yang direntangi oleh
keadaan Bell fi plus dan kita boleh perhatikan bahawa dua penjana penstabil kita bertindak secara remeh ke atas vektor ini dengan mempertimbangkan
dua ungkapan ebit yang ditunjukkan di skrin berserta tafsiran penjana-penjana penstabil sebagai pemeriksaan pariti dalam asas 01
dan asas plus minus kod steam 7 qubit adalah satu lagi contoh kod CSS kerana untuk
pilihan penjana ini kita hanya ada penjana penstabil Z dan X dan sekali lagi kita sudah tahu bahawa ini adalah
kod penstabil yang sah dan kod Short N9 qubit adalah satu lagi contoh kali ini kita ada enam penjana penstabil Z
dan hanya dua penjana penstabil X dan itu baik tidak perlu ada keseimbangan atau
simetri antara dua jenis itu walau bagaimanapun adalah kritikal bahawa kita memang ada kod penstabil yang sah dan itu bermaksud
setiap penjana penstabil Z mesti bertukar dengan setiap penjana penstabil X jadi anda tidak boleh
cukup pilih dua jenis penjana secara bebas dan saya akan katakan sedikit lagi tentang ini kemudian dalam pelajaran seterusnya kita akan bincangkan pengesanan
dan pembetulan ralat untuk kod CSS dan apa yang kita akan jumpa ialah sifat yang kita perhatikan untuk kod Shore 9 qubit
bahawa kita boleh mengesan dan membetulkan ralat X dan ralat Z secara bebas berlaku secara umum untuk kod CSS
untuk jelaskan ini lebih lanjut jom kita pertimbangkan kod CSS seperti kod steam 7 qubit tapi ia boleh menjadi kod CSS yang berbeza jika
WEBVTT
anda lebih suka idea asasnya ialah penjana penstabil Z mengesan ralat X
tapi ia sama sekali tidak peduli tentang ralat Z kerana penjana penstabil Z sentiasa bertukar dengan ralat Z
selain itu penjana penstabil Z juga bertukar dengan apa sahaja gate Z yang mungkin kita pilih untuk gunakan sebagai
pembetulan untuk ralat Z begitu juga penjana penstabil X mengesan ralat Z tapi ia sama sekali
tidak peduli tentang ralat X dan pembetulan jadi pada dasarnya kita boleh fikirkan tentang penjana penstabil Z sebagai mewakili
kod linear klasik yang melindungi terhadap balik bit atau dalam erti kata lain ralat x sementara penjana penstabil X
mewakili kod linear klasik dalam asas plus minus yang secara sepenuhnya bebas melindungi terhadap balik
antara keadaan plus dan minus atau dalam erti kata lain ralat balik fasa atau ralat Z jadi sekarang agak jelas apa yang berlaku
dengan kod Steane ia hanyalah kod Hamming 743 untuk ralat balik bit dan kod Hamming 743 untuk ralat balik fasa
sekali lagi fakta bahawa penjana penstabil Z dan penjana penstabil X bertukar adalah diperlukan ia
tidak akan menjadi kod penstabil yang sah jika tidak dan anda boleh katakan adalah nasib baik bahawa kod Hamming 743
berfungsi seperti ini tapi ada banyak pilihan lain yang boleh dibuat untuk pasangan kod linear klasik yang akan memberi kita kod penstabil yang sah
apabila digabungkan dengan cara ini sekarang kembali kepada kod CSS secara umum katakan penjana penstabil Z
membenarkan pembetulan sehingga katakan JX ralat dan penjana penstabil X membenarkan pembetulan
sehingga k ralat z jadi dalam kes kod Steane J dan K kedua-duanya satu kerana
kod Hamming 743 boleh membetulkan satu balik bit tapi secara umum nombor-nombor J dan K ini boleh berbeza
kemudian mengikut dari diskretisasi ralat bahawa kod CSS boleh membetulkan mana-mana ralat pada bilangan qubit sehingga
minimum J dan K itu kerana apabila kita ukur sindrom ralat sewenang-wenangnya pada beberapa
qubit secara berkesan runtuh secara kebarangkalian kepada sesetengah kombinasi ralat X ralat Z atau kedua-duanya dan kemudian
ralat X dan ralat Z boleh dikesan dan dibetulkan secara bebas jadi selagi kita ada dua
kod linear klasik yang serasi dalam erti kata ia memberi kita penjana penstabil x dan z yang bertukar
kod CSS yang kita dapat dengan menggabungkannya pada dasarnya mewarisi sifat pembetulan ralat kedua-dua kod dalam erti kata yang baru saya
huraikan perhatikan bahawa ada harga yang perlu dibayar bagaimanapun iaitu kita tidak boleh enkod sebanyak qubit sebagai bit
dengan dua kod klasik kerana jumlah keseluruhan penjana penstabil untuk kod CSS adalah jumlah
bilangan pemeriksaan pariti untuk dua kod klasik dan setiap penjana penstabil memotong dimensi ruang kodee
separuh misalnya kod Hamming 743 membenarkan pengekodan empat bit klasik kerana kita hanya ada
tiga pemeriksaan pariti untuk kod ini sedangkan kod steam 7 qubit hanya mengekod satu qubit kerana ia mempunyai enam
penjana penstabil perkara terakhir yang akan saya jelaskan tentang kod CSS secara umum dalam pelajaran ini berkaitan dengan ruang kod kod CSS
dan bagaimana rupanya dan ini juga akan memberi kita peluang untuk memeriksa dengan lebih terperinci hubungan yang perlu berlaku antara
dua kod linear klasik agar serasi dalam erti kata bahawa kita boleh menggabungkannya bersama untuk membentuk kod CSS
pertimbangkan kod CSS sewenang-wenangnya ke atas N qubit dan biarkan Z1 hingga Zs menjadi rentetan pemeriksaan pariti n-bit
yang sepadan dengan penjana penstabil Z ini bermaksud kod linear klasik yang diterangkan oleh penjana penstabil Z yang kita akan panggil CZ sekadar untuk membantu kita ingat bahawa ini
adalah kod yang sepadan dengan penjana penstabil Z mengambil bentuk yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin dalam kata-kata kod itu mengandungi setiap
rentetan U yang hasil darab binarinya dengan setiap rentetan pemeriksaan pariti adalah sifar baik jika kita mahu kita juga boleh
mempertimbangkan kod berbeza yang berasal dari rentetan yang sama ini yang kita akan panggil DZ dan idea di sini ialah kita fikirkan tentang
rentetan-rentetan Z1 hingga Zs ini bukan sebagai rentetan pemeriksaan pariti tapi sebaliknya sebagai penjana
pada ketika ini tidak jelas kenapa kita mahu fikirkan tentang kod ini tapi kita boleh dan ia akan rupanya relevan dengan
perbincangan ini kod ini dipanggil kod Dual bagi CZ dan ia biasanya ditandakan CZ superskrip perpendikular iaitu CZ dengan simbol
perpendikular sebagai superskrip tapi kita akan panggil ia DZ dan itu akan cukup mudah untuk diingat kerana D adalah singkatan untuk
dual kita juga boleh buat sesuatu yang serupa dengan penjana penstabil X jadi kali ini CX adalah kod linear klasik
yang rentetan pemeriksaan paritinya sepadan dengan penjana penstabil X dan DX adalah kod Dual bagi kod ini sebagai catatan sampingan
kita kini boleh menerangkan syarat yang mesti berlaku agar CZ dan CX serasi dalam erti kata kita boleh
gandingkan keduanya bersama sebagai kod CSS dalam sebutan kod-kod ini sendiri khususnya mesti bahawa
DZ terkandung dalam CX atau secara setara bahawa DX terkandung dalam CZ dan sekarang adalah
mungkin untuk menerangkan ruang kod bagi kod CSS yang berasal dari dua kod ini dan satu cara untuk menerangkannya ialah ia
adalah ruang yang direntangi oleh semua vektor yang mengambil bentuk yang ditunjukkan di skrin dalam kata-kata ia kelihatan seperti
superposisi seragam ke atas rentetan-rentetan dalam kod Dual DX bagi kod yang sepadan dengan penjana penstabil X yang dianjak
oleh atau di-XOR-kan dengan rentetan-rentetan dalam kod CZ yang sepadan dengan penjana penstabil Z dan kita akan lihat bagaimana rupanya ini
dalam kes khusus kod Steane sebentar lagi ini masuk akal kerana keadaan-keadaan dalam ruang kod mesti merupakan vektor eigen tambah satu bagi semua penjana penstabil dan khususnya mendarab dengan mana-mana satu daripada penjana penstabil X
adalah setara dengan XOR-kan dengan rentetan X yang sepadan itulah sebabnya superposisi seragam
ke atas DX yang dianjak oleh rentetan berbeza muncul seperti ini pilihan berbeza untuk anjakan
yang diwakili oleh rentetan Y dalam ungkapan ini boleh memberi kita vektor yang sama ngomong-ngomong jadi keadaan-keadaan ini bukan semuanya berbeza tapi secara kolektif ia merentangi
keseluruhan ruang kod ada simetri di sini antara penjana penstabil x dan z dan
kod yang bersesuaian dengan keduanya dan jadi kita boleh gunakan simetri itu untuk menerangkan vektor dalam ruang kod dengan cara yang analogus dengan menukar x dan z tapi
kita juga perlu menukar asas piawai untuk asas plus minus itulah sebabnya operasi Hadamard muncul dalam
ungkapan ini sekarang untuk contoh yang dijanjikan iaitu kod Steane kita berakhir dengan dua ini sebagai kemungkinan
pengekodan keadaan asas piawai sifar dan satu khususnya kita boleh enkod keadaan sifar sebagai superposisi seragam
ke atas lapan rentetan dalam kod Dual bagi kod Hamming 743 yang rupanya adalah separuh daripada rentetan dalam kod Hamming 743 dan kita
boleh enkod keadaan satu dengan cara yang serupa kecuali bahawa semua rentetan di-XOR-kan dengan rentetan semua satu dalam kes ini
kerana rentetan itu kebetulan ada dalam kod Hamming 743 tapi bukan dalam kod dualnya satu ulasan terakhir di sini ialah kita kerap
tidak terlalu ambil berat tentang bagaimana rupa vektor-vektor dalam ruang kod kita kerana secara umumnya kita tidak perlu tahu ini untuk menggunakan
kod jadi jika penjelasan ini tidak jelas ia sebenarnya bukan sesuatu yang perlu dibimbangkan terlalu banyak tapi ia memang
WEBVTT
semula jadi untuk bertanya bagaimana rupa vektor-vektor dalam ruang kod bagi kod CSS dan penerangan ini memberikan jawapan kepada
soalan itu seterusnya kita akan bincangkan kod CSS khusus yang dikenali sebagai kod Torus yang merupakan contoh sesuatu yang dikenali sebagai
kod pembetulan ralat kuantum topologi kod ini ditemui oleh Alexei Kitaev dalam
tahun 1997 sebenarnya kod Torus bukan satu kod tetapi sebaliknya ia adalah keluarga kod satu untuk setiap integer positif sekurang-kurangnya
dua kod-kod ini mempunyai beberapa sifat utama sifat utama pertama ialah
semua penjana penstabil mempunyai berat rendah sebagai operasi polinomial khususnya semuanya akan mempunyai
berat empat dan ini bagus kerana bermaksud setiap pengukuran penjana penstabil tidak perlu
melibatkan terlalu banyak qubit kadang-kadang orang bercakap tentang kod ldpc kuantum atau kod pemeriksaan pariti ketumpatan rendah Kuantum
dan inilah yang dimaksudkan dengan istilah ini di mana dalam kes ini rendah bermaksud empat jadi kod Torus adalah contoh
Kod ldpc Kuantum kod Torus juga mempunyai apa yang dipanggil lokaliti geometri yang bermaksud bukan sahaja
penjana penstabil mempunyai berat rendah tapi ia juga mungkin untuk susun qubit secara ruang supaya
setiap pengukuran penjana penstabil hanya melibatkan qubit yang berdekatan yang menjadikan pengukuran-pengukuran ini lebih mudah untuk dilaksanakan secara
prinsip dan akhirnya kod-kod ini mempunyai jarak yang besar jadi ia boleh bertolak ansur dengan kadar
Ralat yang agak tinggi inilah cara kod-kod ini berfungsi pertama biarkan L huruf besar menjadi integer positif
yang sekurang-kurangnya dua dan pertimbangkan kekisi L kali L dengan apa yang dipanggil sempadan berkala misalnya ini adalah kekisi L kali L untuk L sama dengan 8 dan perhatikan bahawa garis
di sebelah kanan dan di bawah adalah garis putus-putus dan idea di sini ialah kita ingin fikirkan tentang garis putus-putus di sebelah kanan sebagai garis yang sama seperti
garis di sebelah kiri dan begitu juga garis putus-putus di bawah adalah garis yang sama seperti yang di
atas jadi jika kita sebenarnya ingin merealisasikan konfigurasi jenis ini secara fizikal kita akan perlukan tiga
dimensi khususnya kita boleh bentuk silinder dengan terlebih dahulu mempadankan tepi kiri dan kanan kemudian bengkokkan
silinder supaya bulatan di hujung-hujung yang dahulunya tepi atas dan bawah kekisi bertemu atau anda
boleh padankan bahagian atas dan bawah dahulu kemudian tepi ia berfungsi kedua-dua cara dan tidak penting cara mana anda buat untuk
tujuan perbincangan ini apa yang kita dapat adalah Torus atau dalam erti kata lain donat walaupun memikirkannya sebagai tiub dalam tayar adalah
mungkin imej yang lebih baik untuk ada dalam fikiran kerana ini bukan pepejal kekisi sebenarnya telah menjadi permukaan
Torus dan dari sinilah nama kod Torus datang cara anda boleh bergerak di sekeliling
Torus seperti ini dengan mengandaikan anda boleh bergerak antara titik-titik bersebelahan pada kekisi kemungkinan besar akan dikenali oleh orang yang telah memainkan video
game lama di mana jika anda bergerak dari tepi atas skrin anda muncul di bawah dan begitu juga untuk tepi kiri dan kanan
skrin dan sebahagian besarnya inilah cara saya akan menerangkan kekisi ini berbanding bercakap secara khusus tentang
Torus dalam ruang tiga dimensi seterusnya kita bayangkan bahawa qubit
diletakkan pada tepi kekisi seperti yang digambarkan di sini di skrin di mana qubit ditandakan dengan bulatan biru pepejal
perhatikan ngomong-ngomong bahawa qubit yang diletakkan pada garis putus-putus tidak pepejal dan itu kerana kita sudah mewakili qubit tersebut
sama ada oleh yang di sepanjang bahagian atas atau sebelah kiri dengan mengingati bahawa garis di atas dan sebelah kiri adalah tepat garis yang sama seperti yang
ditunjukkan oleh garis putus-putus di bawah dan kanan dan jadi jika kita kira semua qubit ini kita mendapat 2 kali L kuasa 2 qubit dan satu
cara untuk melihat itu adalah dengan perhatikan bahawa kita mendapat L kuasa 2 qubit pada tepi mendatar dan L kuasa 2 qubit pada tepi menegak
jadi itulah susun atur qubit kita dan untuk menerangkan kod Torus itu sendiri kita hanya perlu menerangkan penjana penstabil
dan ada dua jenis pertama kita ada penjana penstabil Z
dan ini sepadan dengan jubin atau petak dalam rajah dan kedua kita ada penjana penstabil X
dan ini sepadan dengan bucu dalam rajah misalnya ini adalah satu
penjana penstabil yang bermaksud kita meletakkan bersama satu operasi polinomial Z untuk setiap qubit yang menyentuh jubin ini berserta matriks identiti
pada semua qubit lain dan itu memberi kita operasi polinomial berat empat dan ini adalah contoh penjana penstabil X
di mana kita ada matriks polinomial X yang bertindak ke atas empat qubit yang mengunjungi bucu ini berserta
matriks identiti pada semua qubit lain jadi sekali lagi ia adalah operasi polinomial berat empat adalah penting bahawa untuk kedua-dua
jenis penjana penstabil ini kita sertakan yang membungkus di sempadan berkala dan ini adalah contoh penjana penstabil x yang
melakukan ini sekarang untuk mendapat kod penstabil yang sah kita memerlukan penjana penstabil
untuk bertukar penjana penstabil Z semua bertukar antara satu sama lain kerana Z bertukar dengan dirinya sendiri dan identiti
bertukar dengan segalanya dan begitu juga untuk penjana penstabil X adalah juga jelas bahawa penjana penstabil z dan penjana penstabil x
bertukar apabila ia bertindak secara tidak remeh pada set-set qubit yang berasingan seperti untuk dua penjana yang ditunjukkan
di sini kemungkinan lain ialah penjana penstabil z dan penjana penstabil x bertindih dan
apabila itu berlaku ia sentiasa dua qubit yang bertindih jadi penjana penstabil bertukar kerana ZZ
dan XX bertukar sekarang ini bukan set minimum penjana penstabil khususnya jika kita darab
semua penjana penstabil Z bersama kita mendapat identiti kerana setiap qubit didarab dengan z dua kali
sekali untuk setiap jubin yang menyentuh qubit itu bermaksud mendarab semua penjana penstabil Z bersama
kecuali satu daripadanya memberi kita yang terakhir itu jadi ia tidak bebas tapi jika kita singkirkan mana-mana satu daripadanya kita akan mendapat
set bebas dan perkara yang sama berlaku untuk penjana penstabil X jadi kita boleh singkirkan satu dari setiap jenis
dan tidak penting yang mana kita singkirkan dan itu meninggalkan l kuasa 2 tolak satu penjana penstabil setiap jenis untuk
jelaskan ini dan ini adalah sesuatu yang saya singgung dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita sebenarnya mengambil berat tentang semua penjana penstabil ini dan dalam erti kata
operasional yang ketat kita sebenarnya tidak akan memilih satu dari setiap jenis untuk diabaikan tapi demi menganalisis kod kita boleh
bayangkan bahawa satu penjana penstabil setiap jenis telah disingkirkan supaya kita mendapat set penjana minimum dengan mengingati
bahawa kita sentiasa boleh menyimpulkan hasil penjana-penjana yang disingkirkan ini dengan menganggapnya sebagai pemboleh ukur dari hasil semua penjana penstabil
lain yang sama jenis jadi bilangan qubit yang dikodkan oleh kod ini sama dengan jumlah keseluruhan
qubit yang adalah 2 kali l kuasa 2 tolak jumlah keseluruhan penjana penstabil dalam set penjana minimum yang adalah 2 kali l kuasa 2
WEBVTT
tolak 2 dengan mengingati bahawa kita boleh sentiasa menyimpulkan hasil penjana-penjana yang disingkirkan yang menganggapnya sebagai pemboleh ukur dari hasil semua penjana penstabil
lain yang sama jenis jadi bilangan qubit yang dikodkan oleh kod ini sama dengan jumlah keseluruhan
qubit iaitu 2 kali l kuasa 2 tolak jumlah keseluruhan penjana penstabil dalam set penjana minimum iaitu 2 kali l kuasa 2 tolak
2 dan itu bermaksud kita boleh enkodkan 2 qubit saya tidak hujahkan ngomong-ngomong bahawa ruang kod itu bukan remeh tapi memang
ia bukan remeh dan saya serahkan kepada anda untuk meyakinkan diri bahawa tidak ada cara untuk darabkan bersama penjana penstabil dengan cara yang memberi kita
negatif -1 kali identiti jadi itulah kod Torus itu sendiri dan pada ketika ini mungkin tidak
jelas sama sekali kenapa kod ini sepatutnya baik untuk pembetulan ralat kuantum ia masih lagi untuk kita analisis dan apa yang kita akan jumpa ialah ia memang
kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang cukup mengagumkan untuk faham bagaimana kod Torus berfungsi sebagai kod pembetulan ralat kuantum
kita akan mulakan dengan mempertimbangkan ralat berbeza dan sindrom yang dihasilkannya perkara pertama yang perlu diperhatikan ialah
kod Torus adalah kod CSS kerana semua penjana penstabil kita adalah sama ada penjana penstabil Z atau X
dan maksudnya ialah ralat X dan ralat Z boleh dikesan dan mungkin dibetulkan
secara berasingan dan sebenarnya ada simetri mudah antara penjana penstabil Z dan X yang membolehkan kita menganalisis ralat X
dan ralat Z pada dasarnya dengan cara yang sama jadi saya akan tumpukan pada ralat X yang mungkin dikesan oleh penjana penstabil Z
dan anda boleh terjemahkan semuanya kepada ralat Z yang mungkin dikesan oleh penjana penstabil X menggunakan idea yang sama tepat
ini adalah rajah yang menggambarkan dua qubit persegi kita pada tepi kekisi L
kali L dengan sempadan berkala dan kita boleh bayangkan ini tersusun di permukaan
Torus buat masa ini semua qubit berwarna biru menandakan bahawa ini adalah qubit yang tidak terjejas oleh
ralat jadi anda sepatutnya bayangkan pada ketika ini keadaan qubit ini berada dalam ruang kod untuk
kod ini seperti yang saya sebut fokus kita akan pada ralat X dan sebentar lagi kita akan gunakan bulatan magenta untuk menandakan qubit yang
telah terjejas oleh ralat X ralat X dikesan oleh penjana penstabil Z yang sepadan
dengan jubin dalam rajah jadi apa yang boleh kita buat ialah biarkan Jubin Putih menandakan hasil pengukuran tambah satu atau dalam erti kata lain
entri dalam sindrom yang sepadan dengan penjana itu sementara jubin kelabu akan menandakan hasil pengukuran tolak satu
anda boleh fikirkan hasil tambah satu atau dalam erti kata lain jubin putih sebagai menandakan bahawa penjana penstabil yang sepadan
adalah gembira segala-galanya kelihatan baik untuk penjana ini baik hasil tolak satu atau jubin kelabu
menandakan bahawa penjana penstabil yang sepadan adalah tidak gembira kerana sudah tentunya ralat mesti berlaku untuk menyebabkan
hasil ini jadi buat masa ini semua penjana penstabil kita gembira kerana tiada ralat berlaku sekarang jika kita fikirkan
tentang penjana penstabil z yang hanya mengukur pariti 4 qubit yang menyentuh jubin dengan
merujuk kepada asas piawai jadi hasil tambah satu tidak menandakan bahawa tiada ralat X berlaku pada empat
qubit ini tapi sebaliknya ia menandakan bahawa bilangan genap ralat X berlaku sedangkan hasil tolak satu menandakan
bahawa bilangan ganjil ralat X berlaku jadi sekarang jom perkenalkan ralat X dan lihat apa yang
berlaku dua penjana penstabil Z yang sepadan dengan jubin yang menyentuh qubit ini kini tidak gembira kerana
ralat x ini anti-bertukar dengan kedua-dua penjana ini atau secara setara dari segi asas piawai kita kini berada dalam
keadaan di mana kedua-dua set empat qubit yang sepadan dengan dua jubin mempunyai pariti ganjil jadi itulah kesan satu
ralat X jadi jika kita ukur sindrom ini dan kita tahu atau kita andaikan bahawa hanya satu ralat X berlaku kita akan dapat
dengan mudah mengesahkan qubit mana yang telah bertukar dan kita boleh cukup balikkan semula dengan gate x sekarang jom lihat apa yang berlaku
apabila kita perkenalkan ralat X tambahan dan khususnya jom lihat apa yang berlaku apabila ralat X kedua berlaku pada
qubit lain yang menyentuh salah satu jubin kelabu katakan jubin kelabu di atas seperti
ini jubin itu kini gembira kerana dua ralat X telah berlaku pada qubit yang menyentuh jubin ini dan dua adalah genap jadi
dua ralat X ini bersama-sama bertukar dengan penjana penstabil untuk jubin ini cara lain untuk menyatakannya ialah
ralat X kedua ini telah menganjak semua keadaan asas piawai bagi empat qubit ini dari pariti ganjil kembali ke pariti genap
jubin di sebelah kiri ralat X baru ini sebaliknya kini tidak gembira
kita boleh teruskan proses menambah ralat X baru ini dan selagi kita membentuk rantai ralat X bersebelahan di mana bersebelahan bermaksud qubit menyentuh
jubin yang sama kita akan secara berkesan tolak hasil pengukuran tolak satu ini keliling dan apa yang kita jumpa ialah kita sentiasa ada
hasil pengukuran sindrom tolak satu di titik akhir rantai ralat bersebelahan jadi kita sentiasa boleh mengesan rantai
ralat X bersebelahan selagi ia mempunyai titik akhir mungkin ada pelbagai rantai tapi kita akan kembali
kepada kemungkinan ini kemudian walau bagaimanapun adalah mungkin bahawa kita boleh ada rantai ralat X bersebelahan yang
tidak mempunyai titik akhir yang bermaksud rantai ralat kita boleh membentuk gelung tertutup jadi jom tambah lebih banyak ralat supaya
ia membentuk gelung tertutup seperti ini misalnya kita kini ada bilangan genap ralat X
pada setiap jubin jadi setiap penjana penstabil kini gembira dan apa yang kita jumpa ialah gelung tertutup
ralat X bersebelahan tidak dikesan oleh kod ini kerana kita mendapat semua sindrom tambah satu dalam
kes seperti itu jadi mungkin kelihatan agak mengecewakan sebenarnya kita hanya perlukan empat ralat X bersebelahan untuk membentuk gelung tertutup
dan kita mengharapkan sesuatu yang lebih baik daripada kod jarak 4 walau bagaimanapun beberapa gelung tertutup
ralat X bersebelahan sendiri ada dalam penstabil ingat bahawa kita ada penjana penstabil X untuk setiap bucu dalam
kekisi dan jika kita darabkan bersama penjana penstabil X yang bersebelahan kita boleh membentuk gelung tertutup operasi X
seperti yang ada di sini untuk gelung tertutup yang kita bina beberapa saat tadi jadi beberapa gelung tertutup ralat X
seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini sebenarnya bukan ralat langsung kerana ia ada dalam penstabil jadi ia tidak buat apa-apa langsung kepada ruang kod walau bagaimanapun ada
beberapa gelung tertutup ralat X yang tidak ada dalam penstabil dan oleh itu ia mewakili ralat tidak remeh yang tidak dikesan
oleh kod dan ada cara yang agak mudah untuk mencirikan jenis berbeza
gelung gelung yang melintasi setiap garis dalam kekisi yang bermaksud setiap garis menegak dari atas ke bawah dan setiap garis mendatar
dari kiri ke kanan bilangan genap kali adalah sentiasa hasil darab penjana penstabil X itu termasuk contoh
yang ditunjukkan di skrin serta gelung yang mungkin lebih rumit termasuk kemungkinan ia melintasi sempadan berkala tapi
WEBVTT
walau bagaimanapun dengan mendarab gelung-gelung tertutup ralat X ini dengan penjana penstabil X ia boleh secara berkesan dikecilkan kepada
tiada dan ia memang benar ngomong-ngomong bahawa kita hanya boleh mendapat gelung seperti ini dengan mendarabkan bersama penjana penstabil X kerana setiap penjana penstabil X
meletakkan bilangan genap operasi X pada setiap garis mendatar dan pada setiap garis menegak
jenis gelung tertutup lain yang boleh kita ada ialah yang melintasi sekurang-kurangnya satu garis bilangan ganjil kali seperti
yang ditunjukkan di sini yang melintasi setiap garis mendatar hanya sekali dan ini adalah contoh lain yang melintasi
setiap garis menegak hanya sekali jadi ini adalah contoh ralat tidak remeh yang tidak dikesan oleh kod tapi kunci
di sini ialah satu-satunya cara untuk membentuk gelung tertutup seperti ini adalah pergi sekeliling Torus sama ada mengelilingi lubang di
tengah Torus atau melalui lubang atau boleh jadi kedua-dua ini adalah sifat topologi
berkaitan Torus ia semua tentang lubang pada asasnya dan itulah sebabnya ini dipanggil kod pembetulan ralat kuantum topologi
dari segi visualisasi kekisi dua dimensi dengan sempadan berkala ini rantai dalam kategori ini mesti
melingkar satu atau kedua-dua sempadan berkala dengan cara yang menjadikannya mustahil untuk mengecutkan gelung itu kepada
titik dengan mendarabnya dengan penjana penstabil X rantai seperti itu mungkin lebih
rumit daripada yang digambarkan di sini tapi ini adalah yang terpendek yang boleh ada rantai seperti itu kerana ia mesti entah bagaimana melingkar
satu atau kedua-dua sempadan berkala dan yang tersirat ini ialah berat minimum ralat tidak remeh
yang tidak dapat dikesan ialah L mana-mana gelung tertutup dengan lebih sedikit ralat daripada itu mesti jatuh ke dalam kategori pertama dan oleh itu
ada dalam penstabil dan rantai ralat yang tidak membentuk gelung tertutup dikesan oleh kod dan itulah sahaja itulah sebabnya kod ini
berfungsi dan apa yang kita akhirnya peroleh ialah kod penstabil 2 L kuasa 2 2 L kita menggunakan 2 L kuasa 2
qubit untuk enkodkan 2 qubit dan kod itu mempunyai jarak L seterusnya saya akan cakap sedikit tentang
membetulkan ralat dengan kod Torus walaupun saya tidak akan masuk terlalu jauh ke dalam butiran jika kita ukur sindrom dan
kita lihat sesuatu selain sindrom semua tambah satu di mana saya bercakap di sini hanya tentang penjana penstabil Z
maka hasil-hasil tolak satu menunjukkan kepada kita titik akhir satu atau lebih rantai ralat X bersebelahan dan kita boleh cuba membetulkan
ralat-ralat ini dengan memasangkan hasil-hasil tolak satu bersama dan membentuk rantai pembetulan X antara keduanya dan semasa
kita buat ini masuk akal untuk memilih laluan terpendek untuk pembetulan kita misalnya jika kita ukur
sindrom seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini maka kita boleh pilih laluan ini antara jubin yang tidak gembira dan gunakan gate X
sebagai pembetulan sepanjang laluan ini tentunya rantai ralat sebenar yang menyebabkan sindrom mungkin
berbeza seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini tapi tidak apa selagi ralat dan pembetulan bersama
jatuh ke dalam penstabil ia juga boleh bahawa pembetulan kita melengkapkan gelung sekeliling
Torus yang buruk kerana dengan melakukan ini kita telah menyebabkan ralat logik jadi strategi pembetulan
sepanjang laluan terpendek membetulkan ralat berat rendah tapi ia mungkin tidak berfungsi untuk ralat berat lebih tinggi tapi tentunya kita tidak boleh
mengharapkan lebih daripada mana-mana kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang lebih mungkin mungkin bergantung pada model hingar ialah kita
perhatikan sekumpulan hasil tolak satu dalam sindrom dan dalam kes ini kita boleh gunakan algoritma klasik yang cekap untuk membantu
kita memasangkan keduanya dan mencari ralat berat paling rendah yang mewakili sindrom seperti yang saya sebut dalam pelajaran sebelumnya
ini mungkin tidak selalu membetulkan penjelasan yang paling mungkin untuk sindrom tapi ia berfungsi dengan cukup baik secara umum
dan ia sentiasa berjaya membetulkan ralat yang mempunyai berat yang ketat kurang daripada separuh jarak L dan saya juga perlu
sebut bahawa ada strategi lain yang lebih sesuai untuk model ralat yang berbeza sudah lebih 25 tahun sejak
kod Torus ditemui dan dalam masa itu ada banyak kerja mengenai kod pembetulan ralat kuantum termasuk
kod pembetulan ralat kuantum topologi lain yang terilham oleh kod Torus serta kod berdasarkan idea yang berbeza
saya pasti tidak boleh berikan anda senarai komprehensif semua pembinaan kod berbeza yang diketahui tapi saya akan menggores permukaan
sedikit sahaja dan sebutkan secara ringkas beberapa contoh yang terkenal pertama rupanya ia tidak
benar-benar penting bahawa kod Torus mempunyai sempadan berkala iaitu ia mungkin untuk potong hanya sebahagian daripada kod Torus dan
hamparkan ia pada permukaan dua dimensi berbanding pada Torus dan apa yang kita dapat dengan melakukan itu dipanggil kod
permukaan misalnya jika kita potong tepi kekisi dalam corak yang ditunjukkan di sini dengan apa yang dipanggil tepi kasar di
atas dan bawah dan tepi halus di tepi dan sebagaimana mestinya kita sertakan kes tepi untuk penjana penstabil
maka kita berakhir dengan kod yang boleh enkodkan hanya satu qubit kali ini tapi kod itu walau bagaimanapun mewarisi yang paling
penting ciri-ciri kod Torus khususnya ralat tidak remeh yang tidak dapat dikesan untuk kod ini mesti
sepadan dengan rantai ralat yang sama ada terbentang dari tepi kiri ke tepi kanan atau dari atas ke bawah
bergantung pada sama ada ia adalah rantai ralat X atau Z masing-masing ia juga mungkin untuk memotong
tepi-tepi secara pepenjuru untuk mendapat apa yang kadang-kadang dipanggil kod permukaan yang diputar dan melakukan itu boleh membantu untuk menjadikan
kod lebih ekonomi dari segi berapa banyak qubit yang digunakan misalnya jika kita ambil kod permukaan ini
dan kita buang sebahagian qubit meninggalkan segiempat yang berorientasi pepenjuru kita mendapat kod permukaan lain
selagi kita nyatakan penjana-penjana penstabil pada sempadan dengan cara yang betul rajah seperti ini
berguna untuk menjelaskan bagaimana penjana penstabil ditakrifkan di mana jubin hitam termasuk yang bulat di tepi menandakan penjana penstabil X
dan yang putih menandakan penjana penstabil Z yang di sempadan ngomong-ngomong hanya 2 qubit XX
atau ZZ penjana penstabil kali ini dan anda biasanya akan lihat rajah-rajah ini diputar sebanyak
45 darjah satu lagi kelas kod yang menarik yang juga jatuh ke dalam kategori umum kod topologi ialah kod
warna saya tidak akan jelaskan dengan tepat cara kerjanya tapi satu cara untuk memikirkan tentangnya ialah ia adalah generalisasi geometri
kod steam 7 qubit jadi jom pertimbangkan kod steam tujuh qubit dan katakan kita menomborkan
qubit kita menggunakan konvensyen penomboran KCET seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin kita kemudian boleh kaitkan tujuh
qubit ini dengan bucu graf yang ditunjukkan di sini dan apa yang kita jumpa ialah penjana penstabil sepadan
dengan jubin atau muka yang terbentuk oleh tepi graf dan untuk setiap jubin kita sentiasa ada penjana penstabil z
dan penjana penstabil X yang bertindak secara tidak remeh tepat pada qubit yang terdapat di bucu jubin
WEBVTT
itu ini bagus kerana sama seperti untuk kod Torus kita mempunyai lokaliti geometri untuk kod ini jadi kita tidak perlu
menggerakkan qubit-qubit dalam jarak yang jauh untuk mengukur penjana penstabil dan fakta bahawa penjana penstabil Z dan X sentiasa bertindak secara tidak remeh pada
set qubit yang sama tepat juga bagus atas sebab-sebab yang berkaitan dengan pengiraan kuantum tahan-ralat yang akan
saya cakap lebih lanjut dalam pelajaran seterusnya kod warna adalah kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang menggeneralisasikan
corak asas ini di mana kita pada dasarnya buat perkara yang sama kecuali dengan graf yang berbeza misalnya ini adalah graf dengan
19 bucu yang berfungsi ini memberi kita kod yang mengenkodkan 1 qubit ke dalam 19 dan ia kebetulan mempunyai
jarak lima ini dipanggil kod warna ngomong-ngomong kerana salah satu syarat yang diperlukan pada graf ialah muka boleh diwarnakan tiga warna yang bermaksud
kita boleh warnakan muka dengan tiga warna dan kita tidak pernah ada dua muka dengan warna yang sama berkongsi tepi
warna sebenarnya tidak penting untuk kod itu sendiri kita hanya ada penjana penstabil x dan z untuk setiap muka tanpa mengira warnanya tapi warna-warna
itu rupanya penting untuk menganalisis cara ia berfungsi jadi itulah dua keluarga
kod yang sangat terkenal tapi ada banyak pembinaan lain yang diketahui termasuk yang berdasarkan idea yang serupa dengan keluarga kod ini serta
yang sepenuhnya berbeza contoh khusus kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang baru-baru ini
ditemui oleh beberapa rakan sekerja saya di IBM dikenali sebagai kod gross yang dinamakan demikian kerana gross adalah selusin
selusin atau 144 khususnya kod ini mengenkodkan 12 qubit ke dalam 144 qubit dan ia mempunyai
jarak 12 saya tidak akan jelaskan bagaimana kod ini berfungsi secara terperinci ia serupa dengan kod Torus kecuali bahawa setiap
penjana penstabil kini melibatkan dua qubit tambahan yang sedikit lebih jauh ia tidak mempunyai pembenaman planar
seperti kod permukaan tapi ia mempunyai apa yang dipanggil pembenaman Biplanar yang bermaksud dua lapisan qubit diperlukan berbanding
satu ia jatuh ke dalam keluarga kod yang dipanggil kod basikal bivariate dan yang sangat luar biasa tentangnya ialah
ia jauh lebih cekap daripada kod Torus atau kod permukaan dalam erti kata bahawa lebih banyak qubit boleh dikodkan sementara secara serentak ia
bertolak ansur dengan kadar ralat yang lebih kurang sama untuk kod gross diperlukan 144 qubit tambahan untuk pengukuran sindrom
jadi jumlah keseluruhan qubit yang diperlukan ialah 288 yang menjadikannya calon yang sangat menjanjikan untuk teknologi hari ini
dan itu mengakhiri pelajaran ini yang telah berkaitan dengan pembinaan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum termasuk kod CSS kod Torus dan
sekilas pandang pembinaan kod Kuantum lain termasuk kod permukaan dan kod warna saya harap anda akan ikut saya untuk
pelajaran seterusnya dan terakhir siri ini berkaitan dengan pengiraan kuantum tahan-ralat yang menangani cabaran melakukan
pengiraan dalam Keadaan Kuantum yang dikodkan menggunakan operasi dan komponen pengiraan yang sendiri terdedah kepada
ralat selamat tinggal sehingga jumpa lagi